Prof: Today what I'd
like to do is focus first on de
Soto,
and then on the larger
question--you have your informal
property back,
Jennifer--and then on the
larger question of what's the
point of all this?
What is the merit of capitalism?
We know a lot of things that
capitalism isn't really great
at,
and we know that it has--if you
let it run its own course,
it is inclined toward
instability and it is inclined
toward stupendous disruption of
the planet.
Yet, I for one,
am a guarded enthusiast for
capitalism.
The underlying point of it must
have something to do with
helping people to have a fuller
capacity to lead their lives.
You might call it a practical
freedom.
The subject for today and for
next Monday bring that out,
that is, today with de Soto and
I'm going to call on several of
you to think about how you would
use 5% of the GDP of a country
to do as much good as possible,
and then on Monday,
The White Tiger,
which illustrates,
quite powerfully,
that increasing the average
income or wealth in a country
can be a wonderful thing,
but seen from the very bottom
cannot be so great.
The protagonist in The White
Tiger is a brilliant
articulator, if you will,
of that problem.
Okay, so the photograph in
front of you is meant to call
forth de Soto's idea of
Braudel's bell jar,
and the foreground,
a vast favela is all
informal property,
and because it's informal
property it is dead capital,
and the background is not only
live capital and formal
property,
but extremely dense piling up
of live capital.
It is an expression of intense
economic activity and
presumably, for the most part,
of great economic success.
De Soto, on pages 160 and 161
has--first of all he has some
typeface there that is small
enough that I can't read it,
and my guess is,
many of you will struggle to
read it.
But at the top of the page he
has a bridge showing his
prescription for the path from
dead capital on the left to live
capital on the right.
Across the top,
the roadway,
if you will,
is the commercial strategy,
the creation of businesses,
the taking of debt in order to
create new enterprises.
Then the process by which de
Soto and his disciples first map
out the problem,
and then engage in a political
and legal strategy to create the
framework for formalized
property all the way to the
bottom of society,
and then the operational
strategies whereby that is
implemented,
a neighborhood at a time,
a favela at a time.
De Soto is deadly serious about
this, and it's a practical
enterprise.
I'm going to Peru at the end of
term to sit in on an attempt by
de Soto and his fellows to
formalize a set of neighborhoods
around a city,
and I hope to write a business
case that will be used in this
course a year from now on that
trip.
Now if you take the totality of
de Soto's book,
the only thing worse than
leaving informal property
informal,
from his point of view,
is force fitting a formalized
system invented in a university
onto an existing system of
informal property.
I'd like to talk about that
with you or a few minutes and
give you a case from my own
experience in an American
setting.
Well informal property,
these are boundaries in an
imaginary informal property
system,
which correspond to the
ingrained habits and customs of
the people who own this
property,
and their inclination will be
always to defend it against
change imposed arbitrarily from
outside.
If you ask smart professors at
The Yale School of Management,
what's the most efficient way
to lay out the boundaries of
property,
they'll give you something like
the red grid here,
with right angles and straight
lines.
Right angles and straight lines
have a brilliant history in
American property law.
President Jefferson laid out a
grid like this on all but the
northeast corner of the U.S.,
of longitude and latitude lines
defining sections of 640 acres,
and the whole development of
the American West is actually
on--
with the exception of the
mountainous areas,
for example, The Sierra Nevadas.
With that exception the whole
country looks like this rec--
rectalinear grid,
and as you fly from coast to
coast,
you can see the grid laid out
in a perfectly symmetrical way,
with center pivot irrigation
interrupting the grid from time
to time,
and an occasional river.
The better way,
according to de Soto,
is to adapt formal systems to
fit informal systems;
to incrementally add the
perimeter meets and bounds shown
here,
and ultimately to convert the
old boundaries to new
boundaries,
the old boundaries being
recognized only by people living
within this little area;
the new boundaries being
recognized all the way up to the
nation's state level;
and in theory,
all the way up to the world
level, if people from another
country are engaged in a
property transaction.
For example,
if the owner of this land seeks
to take debt from a bank in New
York and the property is in
Peru,
the whole world system is
involved in the formalization,
and the obligation of the
Peruvian government to honor a
contract with an American bank
would come into play.
And so even at the very lowest
level, the ultimate chain of
connections to the top level of
government on a world scale is
important.
Nearly twenty years ago,
a fellow named Kurt Schmoke,
Yale class of 1970,
and sometimes senior fellow of
The Yale Corporation,
was Mayor of Baltimore.
I didn't actually have him as a
student here but I was working
then on cities that had too much
housing,
which I called "under
crowded cities."
You read all the city planning
books from that period,
it's all about how do we handle
all this new population that has
to be housed,
and of course the real story
for a city like Baltimore,
was a vast housing surplus.
Anybody come from Baltimore?
I'll settle for Washington or
Philadelphia,
or Wilmington,
what have we got in the back
there?
What city?
Student:  Washington.
Prof: Okay can you--can
you give us a feel for what a
neighborhood constructed of row
houses looks like?
How it's organized.
Student:  Well I can
tell you about Baltimore because
I see it on the train.
It looks like all the houses
are boarded up,
all the backyards are trashed,
and there's a lot of vacancy
and just desolate wasteland.
Prof: Okay,
it's still a mess,
right?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Which means I was
not very effective,
and Mayor Schmoke was not very
effective.
The difficulty with--row houses
are what the economists call an
inferior good.
The standard Baltimore row
house is nine feet wide,
the widest are 16 feet wide,
so it's like living in a
railroad car,
or in--if it's a tall one,
two or three railroad cars
stacked on top of each other.
By and large,
people prefer ranch houses,
which are more--which more
nearly approximate a square
layout.
People also don't like living
around visible signs of decay
like the ones just described.
When I came on the scene,
this is a very abstract
representation,
but the green dots
represent--the squares represent
property units and the green
dots represent occupied units,
the yellow dots represent units
that are still standing but
condemned,
and the blank units represent
areas where the house has been
torn down.
There's no precision in what
I'm doing here but it'll show
you the difficulty of trying to
change something for the better.
I didn't even know de Soto's
work at this time,
but I was acting on the same
general intuitions that he has;
that we're at the edge of the
bell jar--this slide's just in
the wrong place,
but the red line is the edge of
the bell jar.
One solution to missing
properties is to install
waterfalls;
this was done as a joke by a
student at Johns Hopkins.
It didn't involve any actual
water or construction;
it's just a photographic joke.
Another approach,
and it's the one that I
advocated,
is to triage neighborhoods and
to take a neighborhood like this
where you have very few occupied
units,
most of what's there standing
is condemned,
and lots of vacant lots.
To say let's find a way to use
the wealth of people living here
to improve conditions in a more
promising adjacent neighborhood.
The first thought is that you
take down the condemned houses
in the unworkable area,
and at the same time,
you offer swaps where you buy
for what it's worth,
which is not a lot,
you buy houses in the
unworkable area from people,
and part of their payment is
clear title to a similar space
in a more promising and nearby
neighborhood.
There is a--we're creating a
market here that has a barter
element in it,
land and a small cash payment,
and an effort to facilitate the
financing of replacement
housing.
So after the people make those
moves, this is theory,
you get a much denser occupancy
grid in the top,
and you get some benefit from
that;
one benefit is that crime
generally goes down.
A neighborhood which is mostly
vacant lots is an invitation to
criminal activity.
The statistics on this area in
Baltimore, and it had hundreds
of areas like this one,
the crime statistics are
brutal.
Another fact is that the
administration of public
services is wildly inefficient
where only a few houses in a
neighborhood have trash to take
away,
where streets need to be plowed
and cleaned,
even when very few people use
them and where police services
are stretched extremely thin.
The idea is to densify one area
at the expense of another,
and then to demolish and
replace the condemned houses in
the stronger neighborhood and
you've made some progress.
Well the first thing
that--what's the first objection
that comes to mind?
What do you do with this?
This now vacant area,
what do you do with it?
Anybody got a suggestion?
Sasha?
Student:  Make it a park.
Prof: Make it a park,
that's good,
and it could be a park with a
huge lake in it,
lakes are much easier to
administer than--
you don't have to mow lakes,
and crime is relatively
scarce--
aquatic crime is,
as far as I know,
rare.
Or in some places,
you make it a golf course.
There's a place in Miami where
they've created a zone where
they've just--
it just grows wildly,
it's largely bamboo and there's
a 12-foot fence around it,
and the thought is that 50
years from now somebody will
figure out what to do with it.
That's one problem,
but there's another set of
problems that are even tougher,
and that is that all these
neighborhoods have leaders.
Leaders are not really very
generous about having you take
their followers away.
People who are say Aldermen,
or people who are head of a
neighborhood development board,
or of a neighborhood crime
watch, they all come forward and
they say,
"This is madness!
These people live in perfectly
good houses where they
are," and the ultimate
effect is to drive the
transaction costs through the
ceiling.
The cost of getting the deals
made is astronomically high.
It's a perfect illustration of
why the Coase theorem is
serious,
because if the transaction
costs are high enough,
even obviously beneficial to
all sides swaps,
just don't happen.
De Soto is dealing with
environments in which
transaction costs are extremely
high,
in which the difficulty of
getting things like this done
are--
is just very, very great.
It's fine for you and I to read
this elegant little book,
but that's very different from
actually accomplishing things on
the street,
so that this triangular
relationship between imaginary
leaders would become a dominant
obstacle to completion of the
task.
Back to Coase.
The thesis, as you will
remember, is that where there
are clear cut entitlements,
a high degree of transparency
and symmetrical transparency,
and low transaction costs,
efficient swaps are feasible.
And on the surface de Soto is
all about clear entitlement.
He's perfectly aware that
without being able to execute
economic transactions,
for example,
borrowing against a clear
entitlement,
very little has been
accomplished.
That if corruption,
for example,
interdicts transparency,
those transactions won't
happen, or if they do they will
be the wrong transactions.
One way to think about how to
use de Soto practically is to
take the three conditions from
this simplified version of the
Coase theorem and put them in a
table with relatively practical
categories that you can deal
with,
and then look for ways in
which, for example,
education might impact
transparency and so on.
I'm going to--what I want to do
is proceed much less formally
than this.
The chart is kind of--it's a
very rigid framework,
it's not a bad framework,
but it's a rigid one.
Now have some of you thought
about how you'd spend 5% of the
GDP of a country?
Wave if you have.
I've got one,
two--more--one,
two--no one in this section?
Three--no one's fessing up in
the front row here.
Over here?
Okay we're going to--there we
are in the back--so we're going
to do some winging here,
I'm afraid.
That's okay.
Now Leslie, will you trade me
places?
There's some chalk--now
what--the exercise is to figure
out if we can create large
increments in useful wealth by
spending money.
Tom is it?
What have we got?
Student:  I think its
education is sort of the key to
everything else.
Prof: Okay you would put
education ahead of any--of all
things?
Student:  All other
things.
Prof: Okay,
help us understand why.
Student:  Because I
think that having human capital
can increase your investment on
everything else,
but without that,
you're not going to have the
people that you need to build
roads,
or expand property rights or
all these other things that de
Soto talks about.
Prof: Okay so education,
a relatively well-educated
populous is a necessary
condition, is that what you're
saying?
Student:  Absolutely.
Prof: Okay are there any
necessary conditions to a
well-educated population?
Student:  Well-educated
teachers I think would be
better.
Prof: Okay so we have to
have well-educated teachers.
Are there any other things we
probably need?
Yes.
Student:
>
food and water.
Prof: Food,
running clean water,
electricity,
all the infrastructure--you buy
that Tom?
Student:  Sure.
Prof: Okay so education
was expensive to begin with,
and now it's looking more
expensive,
so we're probably going to need
more than 5% of GDP to get very
far with that but that's a good
thing.
Tal?
Student:  The other
problem with education is that,
unless the opportunity costs of
the education for those workers
are not extremely high,
they're not going to go school.
The kids will end up trying to
make as much money as they can
to support their families,
and so would not end up
actually educating the populous.
Prof: Absolutely,
spot on.
There's an incident in White
Tiger which is exactly about
that,
where the uncle comes and drags
our protagonist away from school
because his labor has been
exchanged in a family deal.
Yes, back?
Student:  There's also a
cultural problem,
like certain societies don't
want females to go to school,
so there's something deeper
than just opportunity costs at
work there that must be dealt
with in other ways.
Prof: I'm sure you're
right.
Can you give a specific example?
Student:  Well I was
watching a movie and it was
about Indian societies in which
women are not allowed to go to
school,
and the figure in the movie,
the leading hero,
was actually based on a real
life figure who went into the
village and convinced all these
different families to let their
children go to school,
because it would be better for
them in the long run,
but not based on opportunity
costs but basically trying to
change their cultural,
kind of closedness.
Prof: What's behind this
prohibition on educating women
do you suppose?
Student:  I think it's
partly to do with the males.
Prof: I'll bet on that,
you think?
Student:  I know that in
certain families as well,
like the female cannot be more
educated then the male.
In marriages--
Prof: A precept I
certainly believe in.
Student:  Sometimes a
family believes that if their
females are too educated,
then they won't be able to
marry them off,
or something like that.
Prof: Okay,
that's terrific thank you.
Yes?
Student:  You also need
infrastructure in place,
and laws in an economy in place
for what they're going to do
after they go to school.
In Cuba they have fantastic
education but no opportunities
for anyone after that's
finished,
so for education to be
effective you also have to
invest in,
sort of like, the next step.
Prof: Okay,
so for education to be
effective we have to have a next
step.
Is the Cuban example one you
know well?
Student:  I wouldn't say
I know it well.
That scares me;
I don't want you to ask me a
question I don't know.
Prof: Well can you--I
mean I've got a couple of--
I've been to Cuba a couple of
times and I have a couple of
Cuba stories that could fill in
the blank,
but how about you try it first.
Student:  I tried to go
to Cuba, but I didn't get a
visa, so I don't know it as well
as I would.
They have--well it has a lot to
do with the communist/socialist
model.
There's just no--there just
aren't any jobs,
there aren't any--so if you're
educated as a lawyer you just
end up being,
like, a taxi driver no matter
what.
Prof: Okay, good.
There's a--I have friend whom I
met in Havana,
who was sort of top five among
the fishery scientists in Cuba,
PhD in biology,
and he was--he kept giving the
wrong advice.
After the Russians pulled out
in the so-called special period,
the government wanted to
double, and double,
and double the harvest of
shrimp, and there are limits on
the ecosystem,
and he kept saying,
"You can't do it,"
and finally they declared him
unemployable.
And the effect of that was that
he became a taxi driver and
trebled his income.
It was still a very low income,
but it trebled what he was
making as a scientist.
Hands over here, yes?
Student:  One of the
downsides of education is brain
drain.
You put all your resources into
educating people but there are
better opportunities in other
countries for them to go work,
make money, and stay there,
so if you are going to put
education as your main emphasis
you need to have some sort of
incentive within your own
country to have people remain.
Prof: Okay,
Tom do you want to answer that?
Student:  I agree that's
a problem but I think it's maybe
less of a problem then it first
appears,
because of remittances,
or even in cases of brain drain
where people are--
get well educated and go be
doctors in America rather than
in India,
they're still going to send a
percentage of that money home in
the form of remittances which
can do a lot in itself to prop
up an economy.
Prof: In the back.
Student:  So I won't
take all the credit for this,
Richard has been convincing me
by degrees as this goes on,
I think, I mean,
you'd rather have 100% of that
income in your country,
and the way to get that would
be through,
for instance,
creating pools of capital in
your country through direct
foreign investment and then the
way you would get that is
through investments and
infrastructure and security.
Prof: Okay,
now we're--we have veered a
long way from education when we
talk about direct foreign
investment.
Would you put that as a high
priority?
Student:  Higher than
education,
because I think that that
comes, but I think you need to
be able to give people jobs and
a livelihood before you can
think about educating them.
Prof: Okay what do you
think Tom?
Student:  I think you're
sort of endorsing the idea of
offering your country up as--
to be colonialized more or
less, in saying that well the
best thing that we can do to
spur our own economic growth is
to offer ourselves as an
extractive nation,
and we'll build the roads for
people to come in,
and take out what they need,
and I don't know if that's the
solution for long term economic
growth.
That's how I would read that
interpretation.
Prof: Richard?
Student:  I think in the
long run in order to build
sustainable growth in your
country,
if you're starting off where
you don't have any of this
infrastructure or educational
facilities in place,
you have to find some sort of
competitive advantage.
At the initial standpoint
that's going to be your labor,
that's going to be your
resources, anything you can
offer up that's going to attract
investment to build out the rest
of these different pillars of
what you need in society.
You can't just start off with,
here's the school and we're
going to educate people and
they're going to keep all the
value within society,
they're going to capitalize on
it, there's not an incentive
based to really do that.
So until you can actually move
up the ladder of competitive
advantage and development of
your markets and education,
and quality of life,
it's sort of putting the cart
before the horse in my opinion.
Prof: Okay.
Now what's fairly obvious in
this conversation is that you've
got to try to do more than one
thing at once.
If we just say education full
stop,
or if we say,
foreign direct investment full
stop,
we're not going to get it done
and there has to be a complex
spiral of these things.
This is why the book by Clark
that we read is so unpersuasive
on this point,
because it takes one thing at a
time and then says,
well that won't do it and it's
the spiraling of several things
at once.
Shoshanna, back there.
Student:  I think the
problem goes back to the
question at hand because with 5%
of GDP you really can't--
I think the problem goes back
to the question at hand because
you can't really do much with 5%
of your GDP so people are more
likely to create this false
dichotomy of options just
because they have limited
resources.
Prof: Okay,
but if this were a real
exercise and you had control
over 5% of the GDP of Cuba or
Peru, or Nigeria what would you
do?
You've got the 5% what's the
first thing you better figure
out?
Student:  I think you
have to focus on getting basic
resources and developing a basic
structure,
so you may have to forfeit your
emphasis on education
immediately.
Prof: Okay,
but what I'm driving at is that
you would want to look at what's
already happening the right way.
You would want to,
say, if there are--
if there are twelve conditions
we're worried about,
you'd want to survey and figure
out that there were three or
four where you could ride
somebody else's dollar so to
speak.
Then you would figure out some
crucial set of others that you
would have to pay your attention
to, does that sound right?
Student:  I think that's
fair.
I think the problem lies in--I
was focusing on central Asian
countries when you gave us this
mini assignment,
and the problem comes when you
devote everything to foreign
direct investment,
when do you stop?
When do you transition back to
meeting all those other criteria
that you laid out in the
beginning?
Prof: Okay,
so it sounds like this is a
pretty complicated subject.
Richard?
Student:  I apologize.
I wanted to clarify what we
were--our point was which is by
attracting foreign investment
the idea is that is not mutually
exclusive,
so instead of taking a limited
5% of GDP and allocating it
towards one aspect of society,
if you can signal to the
broader markets that you're an
attractive investment place
you've now grown that pool of
capital such that it can be
invested through all the
different aspects of what you
need to build society as opposed
to cherry picking one over
another.
That's the goal of attracting
multiple investors.
Prof: One of--so the one
thing that we're at least clear
about is that there is no secret
sauce,
there's no one secret sauce
that is going to get this job
done.
It's vastly more complex.
Now who--did you have your hand
up a moment ago?
Student:  I think it's
>
Prof: Been covered?
Student:  I think it has.
Prof: Okay.
Who will give us a fresh start
with a--
Student:  I was going to
say that what de Soto keeps
emphasizing is the importance of
political leadership,
and what he forgets is that in
many of these developing
countries,
the political leadership itself
is very corrupt,
and it's not within the
leadership's best interest to
move the society forward,
so I thought that empowering
education would give us better
leaders that would follow de
Soto's ideas of transforming
debt capital
>.
Prof: So you and Tom are
playing the same tune,
more or less?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Same tune,
slightly different rationale.
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Okay good.
Student:  I was just
about to add to that with an
example, actually,
of a Kosovo case that I had
experienced this summer.
When I was in Kosovo they had a
hard time attracting leaders
because most of them fled as
refugees in the 1999 war,
so the USAID program had
invested, instead of like this
foreign direct investment
project,
there are projects in that as
well,
but a professional studies
course that educates leaders,
particularly in finance and
investments and these sorts of
things,
so it's bringing the brain
drain back--
like back into the country,
and investing in leaders
instead of--
so then once they have an
efficient leadership base they
can go out and do these things
themselves.
Prof: Did I just hear
you say that MBA education is
the most important thing in the
world?
Student:  Wouldn't that
be nice.
Prof: Thanks.
Who would--are there--why am I
doing that?
Who would start us with an
entirely different starting
point, yes?
Student:  I don't know
how you would do this with 5% of
the GDP but I think if there
were secret sauce it would be
efficiency and low transaction
costs.
This is coming from my
experience in Latin America,
which, I've worked there and
I've traveled there,
and I don't even understand how
they do business there ever,
because it's so inefficient.
Like down to little things,
like I know in Buenos Aries
they don't have enough coins but
you can only pay with coins to
ride the bus,
but there's a shortage of
coins, and so sometimes you just
can't get on the bus because you
have cash but you don't have
coins.
It's little things like that,
but I don't know how you
would--
like where you would even begin
to invest to make those things
more efficient,
but I think the foreign direct
investment and the competitive
advantage flow from that.
You're not going to be a good
candidate unless you have low
transaction costs within the
country.
Prof: Okay.
What I think I hear you saying
is that you've got to get the
Coase theorem working?
Student:  Right and that
has something to do with
corruption, or a lot to do with
corruption of the government,
and the legal system.
Prof: Okay, good.
Yes?
Student:  A couple of
things that I'd do here.
If you're getting 5% of the
GDP, one thing that we should
keep in mind is that we can
assume that the economy will go
on forever,
so I would not spend 5% of the
GDP in that way given here.
I'd divide it over a number of
years.
The second is that the money
that I'd be getting,
I would not leave a penny in
the hands of the government.
I would give it to the private
sector and ear market a thousand
villages and ask the private
sector to use that money in that
thousand villages.
The next year,
based on their performances,
the second allotment that I
would get out of that 5% of the
GDP would be again given to the
private companies who have
performed well.
Now I'll leave it up to them
how do they want to develop the
villages,
it can be a holistic
development, it can be
incomplete development,
it can be corrupt development,
but the second year's resources
would be only going on the basis
of the quality of the
development.
Prof: Okay so what you
want to do is put as much rocket
fuel as you can in the rockets
that are already moving?
Student:  Exactly,
but make sure that the
rockets--the next year the
rockets move based on the
performance of the rockets.
Prof: Okay and if you
were a public official would
there be some problem about that
do you imagine?
Student:  A lot of
problems.
Prof: Right,
because the natural tendency is
to redistribute from the
functioning rockets to the
non-functioning rockets.
The axiom we saw twenty times
earlier in term about how a
defining characteristic of
capitalism is that failing
enterprises fail,
right, and that's one of the
ways capitalism becomes a
learning machine.
You are a cruel but wise man.
Yes?
Student:  In many ways,
this is I guess the--
sort of the opposite of the
last comment,
but you could also see some
validity to the point of using
that money to try to improve
government capacity in a sense,
because, as we've been
discussing, the government is
really a strong point for
creating the stability needed
for investment in other parts of
the economy.
So if there was some way to,
say, use the money to increase
the reach of the government into
more rural regions of the
country,
or to create secure borders,
things like that.
I think that that could have a
potentially positive effect,
and it's sort of a more direct
and centralized use of it,
so it might be a little bit
easier.
Obviously you run into problems
with corruption in government
and, not that that's minor.
Prof: Okay.
That's a very plausible
thought, where you have a weak
state which doesn't have the
ability to actually enforce the
law or to carry out policy in an
effective way,
say, in rural areas.
Think of Western China or large
chunks of Afghanistan,
or nearly all of Somalia;
strengthening the state if
you've got the right incentives
for the people who benefit
directly from the increment of
power.
You've got to have the right
people there with the right
incentives,
and if you have the wrong
people and the wrong incentives,
you're actually going to make
things worse.
Tal.
Student:  I sort of have
two different--very different
ideas.
One that's sort of bottom up
and one that's sort of top down,
from two different parts of the
world.
The first one that's sort of
bottom up would build on the
work of,
sort of, micro finance,
especially in India and
countries like that,
where we've seen that if you
give entrepreneurs,
even at the village level,
some basic capital they can--
even based on their dead
capital, sort of,
they can turn it into live
capital themselves,
especially women.
And if you can focus on that
you can maybe build up sort of a
local economy that's sustainable
in its own right,
and not just sort of at the
whim of FDI.
At the same time,
to use a part of the world that
I'm a little more familiar with,
Israel--my parents are from
Israel,
I spent a good deal of time
there, used to be--
it was built up on the Kibbutz
system,
socialist system,
and had many of the same
problems of the former Communist
nations almost at first,
and then transitioned into a
much more capitalist market
oriented economy,
one that is arguably quite
strong.
Part of the way that was
accomplished was,
as much as it pains me to say,
through state sponsored
enterprise much in the way that
China accomplished it.
In the sort of building up of
basic utilities and
infrastructure and the companies
that served the people's needs
for those and then sort of
spread outwards and actually
turning that informal sort of
communal property into
individual property and live
capital.
Prof: Okay,
let's stop and take stock here
for a minute.
We've heard a dozen or fifteen
points of view,
every single one of them
intelligent, and no single one
of them any major fraction of an
answer.
There is some pattern of
webbing together different
strategies and of custom fitting
those strategies to the
circumstance of actual countries
and actual cultures,
anfd actual governmental
systems, and actual
infrastructure systems.
We've said very little so far
today about infrastructure,
and arguably trains,
planes, harbors,
all that should be an
important, at least late stage
and very possibly middle stage,
element in a strategy.
Next time we're--our text is
The White Tiger, and I
would like to be able to call on
you to bring forth the anecdotes
from White Tiger because
we're going to use it as
follows: the circumstances
described in this brilliant
novel are almost invariably
circumstances that are
destructive of wealth formation,
and so think about the events
which happen in the book,
and then, in class,
we're going to flip them on
their heads,
so to speak,
and talk about what might be
beneficial to the protagonist,
and more generally,
to village India,
and village Indians who come,
in the language of the book,
out of the darkness into the
cities.
I'll show you a short film clip
of a company called SELCO,
which is in the business of
making off-grid electric
lighting for village India.
Then before the end of term
you'll see a full business case
about this company.
It's a for-profit company,
and it depends on micro finance
to sell lighting.
There are many parts of India
where there just isn't any
artificial lighting and
the--it's quite an inspiring and
interesting case.
So I'll see you on Monday and
if you haven't yet read every
last page of White Tiger
I'd do it over the weekend.